videos that define the growing tensions
in the state of karnataka in southern
india students aligned with hindu groups
heckler woman for wearing a bulkha as
competing religious chants are heard
every religion has freedom they are
following their culture and i'm
following mine they should let us follow
our culture and not raise obstacles for
us
a few weeks ago six teenage students
were barred from wearing headscarves in
the classroom those protests have now
spread across the state with more women
demanding the right to cover their heads
in class
opposing them are hindu groups they've
been marching wearing saffron-coloured
scarves and shawls and some hoisted a
saffron flag the color is considered
sacred by many hindus
uniform is same for everyone whether it
is hindu muslim or christian they should
abide and wear uniform and the hijab has
to be kept outside the gate
the state government run by prime
minister narendra modi's party janta
party has supported school and college
administrators in banning muslim girls
wearing head scarves in class the rao
has reignited the debate about minority
rights in india that these hindu
supremacist groups are the same you know
the self-same groups that since 2008 uh
attack women in the same coastal
karnataka area for visiting pubs for
wearing western clothes uh they
valentine's day is coming up and the
same groups will be out on the streets
heckling couples lovers who are sitting
together and saying that you're not
allowed to fertilize uh with somebody
who's not your husband and so on so
these are extremely regressive groups
there is nothing feminist about their uh
objection to hijab
they are merely trying to uh prevent any
uh you know shrink the spaces for
muslims in colleges and shrink the
spaces for interaction between hindu and
muslim
the state government closed all high
schools and colleges until friday while
the high court judges hear legal
arguments and decide whether or not the
law on constitutional freedoms is being
broken
bhavni mithal al-jazeera new delhi